every three minutes someone dies of
cancer day after day week after week
month after month cancer kills close to
200,000 of our people each year yet more
than one-third of these deaths can be
prevented fear ignorance superstition
are responsible for the needless
casualties my terrible disgrace they say
she died of cancer I'm sure that she
caught it but that old isn't so and so
cancer germs were all over the place
once you get cancer that's all brother
you're through that's one thing that
can't be cured a friend of mine told me
about a new medicine for cancer that's
wonderful you don't have to have an
operation everybody knows it's inherited
none of my folks had cancer so I don't
have to worry don't be a sucker
everyone's chances of developing cancer
are just about the same regardless of
heredity we all have to be on guard
no case of cancer has ever been cured by
patent medicine sighs tastes pointment
or other quack treatments cancer is no
more of a disgrace than pneumonia or any
other disease cancer is not contagious
many people are being cured of cancer
every day now to study cancers effect on
the human body let's assume that our
organs are like a group of interrelated
factories raw materials are brought to
the factories by the bloodstream which
travels through the arteries
waste products are carried away by the
vein and limp
canal the cells of the body may be
thought of as workers in these factories
these cells work smoothly along on their
routine job of keeping the body alive
and healthy
occasionally a cell died when this
happened a healthy cell nearly divides
itself to fill the gap when the gaps are
filled by new cells the division stops
and the cells go on with their work this
is normal cell behaves and most people
live out their lives in this untroubled
fashion once in a while something goes
wrong with the normal cell and Kent's
are originated
healthy normal cell turns into a
malignant cancer cells
it feels food from the normal sense
dividing and multiplying relentlessly
cancer cells crowd out the active
working
since cancer starts with one cell it can
be cured if it is treated while it is
still in its original place by removal
through simple surgery
by radiation from x-ray tube
I raised emanating from radium
when every single cancer cell is removed
by surgery or destroyed by x-ray or
radium the patient is cured if cancer is
not destroyed when it is localized
here's what happens
this small cancer growth in the breast
is neglected now we're in trouble the
cancer cells have escaped from their
original location and are getting into
the lymph canal although in some cases
cancer cells travel through the
bloodstream as well the malignant heart
is on its way to invade other parts of
the body the invading horde reaches the
lymph nodes under the arm this is the
last check
because when the cancer cells escape
from this lymph node they move from the
armpit to the point in the base of the
neck where the lymph pours into the
bloodstream
now they are pumped by heart a queue to
the lung where many new cancers develop
the blood then carries some of the
cancer cells from the lungs back to the
heart which pumps them out through the
arteries to all parts of the body
when the neglected cancer has spread
throughout the body there is no hope of
you fortunately many cancers can be
cured if recognized and treated in time
so look out for these danger signals any
sore that does not heal particularly
about the tongue mouth or lips a
painless lump or thickening especially
in the breast lip or tongue irregular
bleeding or discharge from any natural
body opening progressive change in the
color or size of a wart mold or
birthmarks persistent indigestion
persistent hoarseness unexplained cough
or difficulty in swallowing any change
in normal bowel habits pain is seldom a
symptom of early cancer so don't forget
these danger signals any sore that does
not heal particularly about the tongue
mouth or lips a painless lump or
thickening especially in the breast
lifts or tongue irregular bleeding or
discharge from any natural body openings
progressive change in the color or size
of a wart
small or birthmark persistent
indigestion persistent hoarseness
unexplained cough or difficulty in
swallowing any change in the normal
bowel habit that's the first symptom
go to your doctor
if necessary he will send you to a
hospital for a more complete examination
than he can give in his office here at
the hospital a highly trained team will
serve this team includes a physician who
has special knowledge of the microscopic
appearance of cancer tissues this
pathologist will be able to tell your
doctor whether the growth you have is
actually camp if it is early treatment
can save your life or yourself and loved
one
you must save yourself
remember the danger signal go to your
doctor at the first symptom
answer must be stopped before it gets
away